deadlines we all face them everyday
things to do places to be since 2016 the
UK has been obsessed with one deadline
in particular wrecks it breaks it grexit
bricks it brexit brexit it's a deadline
that has been pushed back several times
we are leaving on March on October the
31st by January the 31st
no after three and a half years of
negotiations it's finally happening we
are leaving the European Union but
although the UK is officially eight it
now enters a transition period which
comes with its own deadlines this is not
an end but a beginning now the tricky
part starts by the end of 2020 Britain
and the EU have to work out a whole new
relationship covering everything from
finance to fish and UK Prime Minister
Boris Johnson has said he won't extend
that deadline but many analysts are
already saying that again that deadline
could be difficult to meet and rushing
things could potentially result in a
messy hasty separation so when will
Britain really be done with brexit at
the past three years or anything to go
by it could be hard to tell Britain's
first self-imposed brexit deadline was
set in 2016 through an inert referendum
on Thursday the 23rd of June Cameron
thought that setting a deadline would
force people to choose so the country
and his party could move on of course we
know the vote didn't go the way he
wanted the British people have voted to
leave the European Union but that didn't
stop his successors from also using
deadlines as a way to coerce consensus
there will be no unnecessary delay and
there can be no turning back
we must leave the EU on October 31 and
if there's one thing we've learned from
brexit it's that deadlines don't always
stick the United Kingdom is leaving the
European Union prime minister Theresa
May lacked the support in Parliament to
get the brexit deal she negotiated
passed into law forcing her to go back
to the EU and ask for extension after
extension showing that without the
backing of the UK Parliament those
deadlines don't mean very much that's
where Johnson comes in and come out of
the EU on October the 31st no ifs or
buts
Johnson replaced her resume in July and
the first thing he did following up on a
key campaign promise was to enforce that
deadline can you make a promise today to
the British public that you will not go
back to Brussels and asked for another
delay to brexit yes and I'd rather be
dead in a ditch but again that didn't
happen just like Theresa May it was
because he had no majority in parliament
lawmakers forced him to send a letter to
Brussels requesting an extension the new
deadline was set for January 31st his
threat of a No Deal exit with Britain
crashing out of the block was
neutralized by Parliament his solution
to call for a snap election only after
winning big at that election was able to
ensure his breakfast deal got through
Parliament and this time finally meet
that deadline of January 31st there are
no two deadlines on the horizon the UK's
transition period with the EU entered
December the 31st never needs an
extension it needs to ask the EU by July
the first analysts have said that it is
likely the UK will be only partially
ready by the end of December 2020 just
like during the brexit negotiation some
EU leaders are already talking about a
possible extension period without an
extension of the transition period
beyond 2020 you cannot expect to agree
on every single aspect of our new
partnership Johnson's strong majority in
parliament means that lawmakers will
cause him to miss another deadline but
he may find that he's left himself too
much to negotiate before the end of the
year and decide to postpone if recent
experience is any guide the UK's brexit
drama could be far from over